hey we got a very strange voicemail
today
it's related to an important topic which
is finding a cure for HIV but it weirdly
pulls patent in a way that I don't
understand take a listen to this David
cure HIV on a second patient like what
does this mean for the future of HIV but
insisting for Truvada what does this
mean for protagonist and what does this
mean for the world and it certainly uh
certainly uh I mean that's like that
that's what I would love feeling I never
thought that would happen especially in
my lifetime
okay yeah listen I don't we'll talk
about I don't know what this has to do
with that I don't think this means
anything for Pat as far as I know and I
have not fully reviewed all of Pat's
medical records but I don't think this
means anything for Pat but if you
haven't been following this there is
there was one case of a supposed cure of
HIV a long term remission maybe is a
better way to say it from about 12 years
ago and this has been something that
doctors have been trying to duplicate
since that happened for about twelve
years this appears to have succeeded
with a London patient okay second person
and investigators are publishing that
report today in the journal Nature and
they're going to pretend some present
some details about this and whether this
is a cure or not remains sort of a
question mark I think formally the
second case is still being called a
long-term remission of HIV the virus
that causes AIDS but it's still a very
very big deal it is extraordinarily
interesting it's inspiring it's
potentially a major medical advancement
but what it has to do with Pat I don't
think is that it has anything to do with
that we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about what is
happening in India Pakistan and the
tensions that are going on and
interestingly the sort of PR war around
the tensions that are taking place there
will also talk about an ancient
planet-wide water system that has been
discovered on Mars which some scientists
say hints at the possibility of alien
life at some point in the past
now and we will also talk about the
latest with the us-china trade deal
suspension or I guess trade deal to
suspend tariffs that may be going on in
the pretzel of logic that is Donald
Trump's trade policy and China policy
all of those stories and many more on
today's bonus show including some tech
updates and a bunch of other stuff
thanks for joining me become a member
become a patron so that you can get the
bonus show and just feel good for
supporting alternative independent media